anyway it's time to talk football and
there is a development as it relates to
the dallas cowboys and
quarterback dak prescott subject to the
franchise tag one year 31.4 million
dollars the way things have been framed
out they were leaning toward that
deadline of july 15 for striking a
long-term deal if they didn't that's
when things could have gotten very
interesting because dak prescott has the
right to hold out into
training camp preseason without giving
up a dime he could have shown up
a few days before the
regular season got his entire 31.4
million the only risk was the cowboys at
some point could have rescinded the
franchise tender made him a free agent
he wouldn't have been able to find
another team at that point and stephen
jones the team ceo told me several weeks
ago that's not something they were going
to do well dak prescott wasn't willing
to take that rick risk chris he's
signing it he's accepting it he's under
contract at 31.4 million now the work
continues on getting a deal done by july
15 your thoughts on dak making this move
that he really didn't have to make right
now
no didn't have to make i can't say that
i'm shocked that he did make it you know
like you said i think the big thing is a
lot of people lose sight of this if
you're not paying attention to the
day-to-day details is he can still
negotiate a long-term deal here as long
as for july 15. you know mike there's a
few things i want to ask you first off
i mean it makes sense yes
you know sign it right now as a football
player you're starting to get into some
intense workouts you're on the field
more a guy like jack prescott probably
lifting weights doing all those things a
little bit more aggressively so you sign
the franchise tender it does protect you
if something were to happen to you we
saw a few injuries of football players
last week and some of their workouts
with other teammates and things like
that so i bet you that kind of like
struck a chord with him and his cat
camp to a degree and then you know mike
the other thing i want to ask you here
do you think
the fact of the lack of a force major
and we don't know how this year is going
to play out do you just get you know
named a paper right now
and get it going and and just in case
there is no football you have a contract
signed and you still have wiggle room to
say you expect money would that be part
of their thinking
well i think
more specifically at a time of great
uncertainty
this is certainty this is 31.4 million
that is fully guaranteed period and
there's not anything they can do about
it now collectively what the nfl can do
and the nfl would argue i believe based
on things i've been told that if there
are no games at all this season then the
players aren't entitled to be paid
because language in the standard
contract implies that the
game checks start when the games start
so if the games never start the checks
never start beyond that there's no
protection this year the protection
comes next year chris here's why this is
important
next year if the salary cap would drop
the franchise tag numbers would drop
under the base franchise tag but for dak
prescott
by rule he's entitled to a 20 raise over
what he makes this year 31.4 becomes
37.68
regardless of what happens with the
salary cap next year so he's locked in
for 69.08 million over the next two
years year to year
and look next year is not guaranteed but
you know what last year chris he played
for two million dollars with no
guarantees with
a long-term contract the cowboys offered
him that he said no thanks i don't want
it i'm betting on myself with two
million in hand this year he's betting
on himself with 31.4 million in hand and
the promise of 20 next year and this
gets back to what we talked about
several weeks ago at the end of the day
when july 15 rolls around all that
matters is what will the cowboys offer
him to get him to trade in the 69.08
million over the next two years plus the
craziness that happens in year three 45
million under the transition tag 54
million under the franchise tag or you
become kirk cousins and walk away
what will the cowboys offer him to get
him to do that that's the question now
and now that he signed the franchise tag
that is framed i think there was a
concern that when they got to july 15
and if the cowboys got exasperated by
him not taking that last best offer they
may say to him hey you know what we
didn't think we were going to present to
tender but if you don't take this we are
that is completely off the table now
once he accepts that franchise tag
well you know i saw that you wrote that
on pro you know profootballtalk.com i
found that interesting i mean yeah would
they have taken that 31.4 million and
you wrote the example i think
specifically was what signage devion
clowney ride with andy dalton as your
starting quarterback and there was maybe
another player you talked about
no exactly making a trade
right you take you take away the 31.4
that otherwise goes to dak you get
clowney you trade for adams you ride
with dalton or maybe you have enough
money left over you can get cam newton
and as we get closer and closer to july
15
and those negotiations maybe get more
contentious and the cowboys just finally
say this guy's never going to accept
what we're willing to pay him that's it
we're done that's gone now and look the
chances of that happening were slim
right now they're none
because they can't take it away they
can't pivot to plan b with andy dalton
and spend that money on others and i
think that
look i think that was a factor in this
it's not going to be anything they can
threaten or suggest and remember the gm
is the owner right so you have a wild
card with the cowboys that you don't
have anywhere else the gm doesn't have
to worry about getting in trouble the
owner the gm can do whatever he wants
because he is the owner and i think that
may knock some guys wobbly when it's
time to negotiate so you try to prevent
that by making it clear going in you're
not going to have that nuclear option
the 31.4 million is essentially in my
pocket
yeah well it it's smart from that sense
it does make sense and you know the
other thing that that first popped into
my brain too you know as far as dak
prescott his agent where they are in
this conversation the camp and mike i
know you wrote this about this on
profootballtalk.com as well but you know
with prescott here he is dallas cowboys
quarterback new head coach
there's certainly people that are you
know arguing on tv and even on social
media i know i have a lot of these
comments on my twitter reactions and
things dak prescott really worked this
much money all of these type of things
okay great doesn't really matter uh but
i do think the one thing is with dak
prescott a true professional he
understands how polarizing of a subject
he is it's a new head coach and this is
something i thought about i mean did we
really think
that dak prescott was
not going to partake in training camp
and have a hold out that way
and i think realistically the answer is
we didn't expect him to be that type of
guy and he's not that type of guy so for
him to be there too he knows okay i'm
going to training camp i'm trying to win
a super bowl we got a team that's in a
window so he just signs it now and gets
it over with so there's no more second
guessing or conversations that way
either and i think that was probably a
big part of it as well
i think you're absolutely right chris he
was not going to hold out in the
training camp or the preseason le'veon
bell three years ago with the steelers
did that stayed away as long as he could
and he plays a position that is more
conducive to plug and play especially
when you've got continuity of coaching
staff an offensive coordinator you know
the offense you stay away as long as you
can and then you show up and you're good
to go although it takes a while to get
to the point where you're good to go for
dak prescott you need the reps you need
the time and he's looking at it as this
is a contract year last year was a
contract year at two million and it
worked out because this year i'm in
position for another contract here at
31.4 million and to get the
37.68 million next year which is the 20
raise over this year he's got to have a
good enough season
and so that that's look i remember when
kirk cousins got tagged by washington
both times he instantly signed it this
is my chance to go out and prove it for
a quarterback that's so much more
important than other positions where you
don't have to be there every step of the
way so dak will be there every step of
the way he'll position himself to have a
great year and then next year if they
can't work out a long-term deal fine pay
me 37.68 million this year knowing that
next year you're gonna have a hell of a
mess on your hands and you may see me
walk away yeah that's right he kind of
uh you know ups the ante a little bit
about next year and everything that goes
along with it and i think it is smart
you know as far as what he's doing there
makes sense and you know mike to your
point quarterback running back you know
all right so running back pass rusher
wide receiver you can get away with
not being at training camp yeah your
biggest obstacle is going to be okay i
need to get back and get into football
shape as a quarterback and especially a
young quarterback and a lot of things
you mentioned uh
mike about dak prescott it's a big year
he wants to be able to puff out his
chest at the end of this year and go
yeah you paid me 31.4 million dollars
but i played awesome i played better
than 31.4 million dollars so he's still
going to be able to threaten them with a
long-term deal or nonetheless like you
said be happy with the 20 raise but the
quarterback position just it's too hard
to miss training camp and play the
financial gamble game as compared to the
other positions there's too many nuances
that have to be learned and talked about
with receivers and tight ends and
different protection calls for offense
alignment let alone it's a new head
coach with a guy that's mike mccarthy
that's gonna teach a guy like dak
prescott you know the ways of his
offense and also a few tricks of the
trade as far as what he teaches his
quarterback or what he used to teach
aaron rodgers to read on these certain
plays and those are little things and
you know intricacies and nuances of an
offense that really take a quarterback
from being good to great and you'll miss
that in training camp and i think that's
the other thing too doc prescott
realizes that i think he's a real
professional we both know that
and uh i think that's why you can't risk
this at quarterback at that position
especially
and when you're a team leader
it's just a given that those are the
things you're going to do chris remember
the blow back le'veon bell got when he
did stay away when he did not show up
and he was getting some friction i mean
the men you're supposed to be leading in
the locker room are going to turn
they're going to look for a leader
somewhere else
and they're going to question you if
you're not there and then andy dalton is
replacing that that leadership
vacuum he's filling the void while
you're gone and it just creates issues
and problems and dak prescott
understands that now as to the contract
itself that may or may not be negotiated
by july 15 chris something you've been
saying all along and this is the
absolute 100 truth
he wants a four-year deal
period and he is dug in on a four-year
deal because if you do a four-year deal
they can still use the franchise tag on
you to make it a five-year deal or then
a six-year deal he is dug in on that
four-year deal he's not letting go if
they're going to get him to sign by july
15 and give up 31.4 this year 37.68 next
year they're gonna have to do a
four-year deal
yeah well i i you know that's the thing
that i'd always heard through the
process that that fourth and fifth year
deal were you know the few huge arguing
points here
and you know i understand it as a player
i do of course i do i'm sensitive to
that you want to get back to the
bargaining table as many times as you
can in your career it's a short career
even if you play a long time in the
history of the nfl as far as what that's
considered you know it's still a short
part of your life and a short part of
your life to make money and support the
rest of your life and family and things
that go along with that
i just you know
i i just wonder what's the cowboy stance
are we just talking pure salary cap
numbers here uh or or what is it that's
kind of the impediment that's in the way
is it guaranteed money those are the
little things we don't really know and
i'm just interested to kind of hear what
what that last other issue is or what's
the last offer on the table you know as
far as what's been offered the dak press
got in his camp at this point
well remember when you have a july 15
deadline the last offer is not going to
get there until we get close to the
deadline because if you make your last
offer well enough in advance you're
gonna get squeezed off of it because
it's driven by the deadline i think the
cowboys are flabbergasted that they're
dealing with a guy who was a fourth
round draft pick never got big money
from a football perspective he's made
some money off the field in endorsements
and you know they want credit for that
but
somebody pointed out to me yesterday
it's not like chad hutchinson and quincy
carter ever got big endorsements just
because they were the cowboys
quarterback you still have to be a good
player and if you're a good player
wherever you are the endorsements have a
chance of coming but and a good person
too
yeah right and you look at what tony
romo did tony romo was undrafted tony
romo wasn't supposed to be in the nfl
when the time came for him to work out a
long-term deal he took less because at a
certain level he's not even supposed to
be there dak showed up and stepped in
for tony romo he saved them when romo
was done
when dak was a rookie in 2016. he
started every game he's been a model
citizen a great leader a great
quarterback
and he's not playing that game of i'm
just going to take less
out of the goodness of my heart because
i can i look he they took advantage of
everything in the cba that allowed them
to force him to play out the full four
years under his rookie deal and they
took advantage of the cba by using the
franchise tag and keeping him off the
open market and using the exclusive tag
so he couldn't even negotiate with
another team that may be willing to give
up two first-round picks
a difference of like four or five
million more so now he has rights he has
opportunities he has leverage and he has
every right to use it and i think what's
driven them crazy
is that he's willing to do it because a
lot of players aren't
yeah well i i'll say i didn't know if i
thought that prescott would be willing
to do it i don't you know just being
around him the things i've heard i
thought he was such a team guy and i'm
not saying he's not a team guy that has
nothing to do with you know personally
negotiating a deal yeah right how many
times do we have to show the picture of
him giving you the side eye when you i
know that you don't need to speculate
you tried to
you tried to negotiate the deal on
behalf of the joneses and he gave you a
look and that looked like this is a
business they treated as a business i'm
treating it as a business no and i
totally get that i respect that and i'm
very sensitive the fact that dak
prescott being a fourth round pick has
not made any money plays a pretty
physical brand of football for the
quarterback position i mean this is a
guy
you know if you go back and look at his
highlights from last year or other years
he's diving in the end zone he's
lowering his shoulder running over
linebackers to get in the end zone do
all those type of things so i i am very
sensitive that i totally get that i just
guess i just like i said i would have
pegged him as more of the i'll take less
for the team and you know again too
uh not the not that i want trip again
well
there it is
oh and look at that i'm wearing the same
shirt today what a coincidence
this thing's still in good shape that
was that was two super bowls ago
but i do think there's a fine line okay
at the quarterback position
and i'm not trying to say this to
disrespect a doc prescott or any other
quarterback out there of doing what is
right for yourself and i understand you
take care of yourself first and also
trying to have the team in your mind to
a degree i know if he wants to be if you
want to be an all-time great and things
like that you might have to sacrifice a
little bit of dollars so you can sign a
few extra players that's all i'm saying
that's all i just know if i was in his
position i would be thinking of those
things i know it's easier said than done
uh but i would like i've always told you
i don't think it would be life-changing
if i had 160 million in the bank instead
of 175 million in the bank i think i'd
rather have maybe more playoff wins or
better receivers or things like that too
and maybe you make that difference up in
you know post career accolades and
commercials or anything like that i'm
just throwing that out there it's where
my my mind would have gone as a player
myself
or you take the approach peyton manning
took and i know
his attitude was it's my job to play
quarterback and negotiate the best
possible deal for me it's your job to
worry about the salary cap and chris the
one thing we can't forget the world is
different than it was when peyton
manning was the quarterback of the
indianapolis colts the
rookie wage scale that arrived in 2011
has dramatically changed
what teams pay out especially the first
round draft picks so
if you have a good scouting staff and
we've seen what the cowboys have done in
recent years how well they've gone out
and found young players who can come in
and contribute even when they are mid to
late round oh like that brexit
keep doing that because the more you do
that the less you need me to take less
and
that's that and you want to get others
to take team friendly deals fine that's
their prerogative i'm not doing it i
play the most important position on the
field and i gave you four years at
peanuts at peanuts and now it's time for
me to get my steak
yeah that's the big thing it's the four
years of peanuts that make it a
different situation and you're very
right the fact that he's a fourth
rounder there is the rookie wage scale
all of those things it's a game changer
here
uh and i think you're right though the
more than anything four years of peanuts
makes him
i don't for lack of a better phrase a
hair more desperate than we see in most
quarterbacks in this situation and i'm
sure he feels like he's got some making
up to do as far as dollars and cents are
concerned and i i do get that and i
totally understand that and support dak
prescott from that standpoint all the
way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports